I wanna be the very best like no one
ever was as artists enough to get first
to catch them is my real test to train
them is my color not here I will travel
across the land searching far and wide
each Pokemon to understand the power
that's inside Pokemon gotta catch up
it's like your salt don't wear my chosen
song baby will pull us through you teach
me and I'll teach you Pokemon gotta
catch em all gotta catch em all Pokemon
Shh the meantime in August older more
its whatcha yawn oh my gosh are you
freaking kidding me this is how people
get into accident no I'm doing autopilot
no why is it curving to stop no you
shinin almost say I'm gonna get you
yes so stupid
tugging you never played this game I
don't plan to my goddamn Jolteon you
didn't like talking about with your
kidding I did this is like your kid like
dream come true but you just be on your
phone even more than what usually do all
he do is you know and then you catch
pokemon and the cheering however pokemon
the freeway that should be so illegal
as you can see that pokemon is not
helping in terms of having conversation
with your boy girlfriend motion pushed I
need meat only oh my gosh awake oh my
God why are you doing this you're stupid
you Xiang them a sec you pissed off yeah
look give me that I put on it give me
much forgive me
I tell you about that yes that came
through you hidden game so much so
negative
it's not the game it's the person who's
playing the game talking about hey it's
away from me and my brother - bought -
my brother and I have been well that's
great but is it a great way for you and
your girlfriend to bond
yes how so what's were in traffic right
now and it's the best time for me to
catch people right and it's perfect time
for your girlfriend to be next to you
and just watch you play okay the
sessions it's not even we have all day
I'm just playing a little Pokemon go
Pokemon though I'm dog food or water
dia no one's a doozy wearisome ebike
told you about the dishes you could do
what ever you want like you said to me
I'm never on my from what are you
talking about rarely on their phone I'm
not touching my phone I'm not I'm
playing Pokemon go I just got into the
game boy you got to go all in tier
because some people like spend the time
of the good player I'm not be some guy
my boyfriend is it is a [ __ ] how come
you can't just be like oh that's so cute
my boyfriend likes to play this game
that he doesn't even play games most of
time is the only game that he never
plays he should be like oh that's cool
or we could be played together as a
couple
yeah and never look at each other's
faces were busy looking or following we
have always taking at each other how
much time that we spent this morning
together they're going to spend all over
Santa Monica together fume you see this
is the problem with girls you guys make
things a lot worse than it actually is
this is like another 10 minute drive 10
minutes out of a whole 24 hours is
nothing is it girl's fault that we want
to bond and just
but what it is it whatever girl's fault
is she does not love you know not what
we wanted but it is what is your fault
is a factory ten minutes out of your day
you have to do this out of a 24-hour
span is not that big if you look at the
big picture things the problem is tiny
let's get angry exactly but that's for
girls huh that's why we're girls every
minute counts every minute with me why
should I stop actually da guei
perspective especially Tuggy we don't
see each other that often every week and
that is understood it's not this so
every minute counts but for you it
doesn't because you're saying also
majority of the time we hang out so it's
fine but for us it's like every single
moment it's not that every minute
doesn't count just because I'm doing
this for a few moments process that's
the zoo but that's different you think
that few moments just doing that is like
it's whatever sure it could be but I
yeah I'm like that because every moment
does count because you live in a fantasy
world you think that a relationship is
supposed to be like two people just
constantly engaged 24/7 no no that's not
real life but we're not doing it 24/7
that's just only the weekend exactly and
that's why we're just doing this for a
few minutes now me if I was doing this
all day or even if I was doing it for 30
minutes I would understand
however it's not even that it's only a
few minutes a few minutes I just want to
be with you
and I understand just not do them but
see you are forgetting perspective right
now I'm not forgetting prospective I
just I want to spend my cell walls that
I know you wanna spend more time with me
I am spending time with you because
you're necessary we're doing this but
I'm not doing it
oh really what about that what's the one
that one time you tell me I don't love
you now side I opened up and I love you
more now and now you do love me every
second is like why is it that I want to
be with you more but you're too busy
doing something even for 10 minutes sure
whatever then we need to love you less
than so that it doesn't bother me you're
crazy I think you get that mean I don't
love you you're an insane person good
there's no medium between you you're
always this way before your own you
never like in between it can't be just
like right here no you're not you're not
just right there because well what you
just did right now is either if I don't
get this but I should just love you less
not tell
I should she goes through bifida I'm not
on the alleles not having a good time
what do you mean you're not having a
good - it's temporary it's ten minutes
out of 24 hours think about it like that
see that's what I'm saying you think
about like it's only 24 hours but I mean
it's only 10 minutes out of the 24 hours
for me
like not typically mean more precious
that's why you're a crazy person because
you're thinking about micro things
instead of macro things that's how
that's all right
no but that's not right then because you
should be thinking about you should be
thinking about the situation as a whole
right so if for me just like oh great
this game makes me happy for a quick
moment I never told you not to do it
yeah but it makes it hard for me to
enjoy it when you're doing this next to
me the only way I could engage with you
so mister you're insane the only life
you crazy woman
oh boy Joe that's the only way I could
engage a song it's a song my dahana [ __ ]
all but I hate this game I hate this
game
you may mean I never told you that is
the thing about girls whatever you find
something that I do you just want to
break it down oh yeah sometimes you look
at me you're like oh it looks like he
enjoys that more than he enjoys time
with me is time for me to destroy it I
like to tease it's fun
oh you like to destroy things that make
me happy Oh what are you like doing
today oh you want to play basketball
here's your basketball what did I really
do that
you're such an exaggeration Wow
can I wait with you just let your crazy
yeah it's all tease right
oh yeah cuz I'm going back to my game up
saying goes always like people to Lisa
10 min and that's more than 10 minutes
no you just said you're teasing you
surprising your point okay here nope
because had your fun
you had your fun and you took away my
ten minutes of me getting on you you
took it away and I miss all these great
Pokemon come on come on oh my god hey
I'm not gonna marry what does that even
mean why do girls do that if you like it
so much
go marry it will even make any sense I'm
gonna marry an app you could this is not
fun anymore
why not she really you know different oh
so everything's always my fault but I
always be real just because I said
everything look at this exactly a future
so like - exactly yeah you have ruined
this whole day thanks dad Lucy is such
an exaggerated perfectly fine just play
my game for ten minutes and now you took
that away from me this is the first game
I've liked in years and I don't even
play games anymore
and now you know I don't play it anymore
it's done
I was so condor - ah okay perfect I
could do like the after you know right
nope no why not huh because it's more
important than you
you know it for me because it for me it
was if you're gonna talk [ __ ] then get
ready because I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna hold it in like we're gonna have a
[ __ ] battle but you've never been to the
fist fight before I've never been that
I've always wanted you to fight somebody
I've always wanted to fight somebody I
don't know about now like I feel like
I've expired like my age like it's just
off well which is what you have a
business that you have like a name to
yourself you can't go walking around
slapping the [ __ ] out of people it
doesn't work that way you start take
that I'll be the very best like no one
ever hot I see you so loud I wanna be
the very best like no one ever was don't
want to catch them is my real test to
train them is my cause no I will travel
the constant searching for a world
he's Pokemon to understand the power
that's inside okay but